you're Jerry Brown see there's a
Republican war on California today
congressman Jeff Denham not part of that
at least today Denham says he has a
coalition of votes including about 50
Republicans plus almost every Democrat
in the house that could force the house
to vote on immigration proposals despite
opposition from some in the GOP many of
those proposals would provide amnesty to
so-called dreamers without getting
immigration concessions in return is it
a good idea joins us tonight actually
thanks for coming on you got it thanks
thanks problems so there's so many
things going on in California right now
and as a native of the state I'm
following him closely it's our biggest
state you know it's a leading indicator
of trends so I think it's worth watching
the state's kind of falling apart in a
lot of ways why would the concern of
foreign citizens citizens of other
countries take precedence over the
concerns of the people of California
shouldn't take one prioritize over the
other but it's a it's an issue we've got
to get resolved it's a national issue we
have control Republicans have controlled
both the House the Senate and the
presidency were elected to lead our
borders not secure we have a million
immigrants that come here every year and
another half a million they come across
our southern border so we've got to have
a resolution we have to I'd like to see
the president get the funding that he
needs for a wall a reporter security we
need to make sure that we're not having
the backlogs that we have in the courts
where we have unaccompanied minors that
end up throughout the country without a
court date or without showing back up we
have to have resolution not on the
border as well as our dreamers that have
graduated in our high schools that are
out there in the workforce today yeah I
mean I feel sorry for a lot of them not
against them personally at all but when
I compared their interests as citizens
of foreign countries against the
interests of native Californians many
former immigrants by the way but
citizens it's not even close
so why at least of my concerns so why
wouldn't you say we're not doing
anything actually until you build in a
penetrable border wall or something that
gives us complete control over who comes
here and who doesn't I think we've got
to do both and we should do both at the
same time I think for us to pass
something through a
republican-controlled House and Senate
we have to give the American public a
guarantee a guarantee that we're
actually going to
cure the border a guarantee that we are
going to solve this issue with the
courts and then ultimately I think that
we have to have certainty for our
dreamers this will give them an
opportunity to come out of the shadows
pay a fine of fee pass a background
check create a safer community and these
are individuals that ninety percent of
them have jobs today some are going to
school some are serving in the middle
the unemployed people in California
American citizens in there are ton
african-american and unemployment rates
really high why would I spend a single
second worrying about the job of a
foreign citizen over the job of an
American like why would I want to give
any foreign citizen a job before every
American has one well first of all today
is tax day I am proud of that our tax
policy is getting put in place and
actually creating jobs across the entire
country there are gonna be more jobs but
I think we also have to know who's
taking those jobs Americans first we
need to make sure that we have an
e-verify system a system that will show
employers and show the country what jobs
are available but ultimately every
industrialized nation has a guest worker
program that allows us to work in
manufacturing or farming I think at
least were in charge of that but we're
you know probably 15 million people here
illegally and no Republican is saying
other than like Steve King is saying we
should send anybody back really let's
let's take ten million they've just go
home where do you send them to I mean
these are kids who were brought here
some of the dreamers I'm trying to
remember the 15 million people in this
country illegally and Republicans don't
mean they're lying to their voters as
you know they're never gonna build
meaningful border controls they're never
gonna send anybody back they've given in
on the basic assumptions of the left
which is everyone who's already here can
stay and become a citizen and vote I
don't think so I disagree no we've made
it we've made great strides along the
border that's not enough there's still
areas of the border that are totally
insecure that you see a lot of people
coming across we can do a much better
job but certainly we have a president
that wants to focus on that the
campaigned on the issue we ought to give
him the resources to get it done
why does the budget the last budget
provide more money for border security
in foreign countries than it does for
our country oh I think that we've got to
pass an overall border security bill but
we just voted I mean
just voted on that and I mean that was
funny well not you guys I didn't vote
for it well no I get a Manning good for
you for not voting for that atrocity I
wish it hadn't been signed but but the
Republican leadership kind of signed off
on it and it literally gave more money
for border security in foreign nations
across the seas it did for us this needs
to be a priority for both parties it's
disappointing that under the previous
administration Democrats every Democrat
in the House every Democrat in the
Senate signed on to the bill that came
out of the Senate that had 42 billion
dollars for border security and now
there's a this has become a political
hot potato to not even give this
president a 25 billion that I think both
parties recognize the fact that he will
spend it that he will build it and build
it quickly and effectively
and that has to be part of any solution
that we have I hope so I mean just as
people voted for it you know it's a
democracy congressman thanks a lot for
coming on I appreciate it it's good to
see you thank you I see you